so
hello
and welcome to the lobby game sports
weekly hangout every tuesday 2 p.m
pacific right here huh
gamespot.com mary you did a lot of work
fixing this camera
only for us to be on this guy there you
go
i think it's the biggest camera in the
world look at this thing is the crane
gonna start like dropping crap on my
head again this week it's so beautiful
it's sunny this week alexa ray korea it
is sunny out mike mccarty isn't it sunny
freezing though peter brown
hello how sunny is it today oh god it's
beautiful
this is what winter looks like in on the
best coast let's be honest it's still
like a chill 45 degrees out there oh is
it 50 degrees yeah it's pretty cold
frisk oh my goodness my nipples are hard
but you know what's not cold oh no
it started
hot video game news
oh we don't have a we don't we didn't
have in the running order because it
kind of broke around but let's can we
have a quick chinwag about what's going
on with uh my chin is primed and ready
to go mr uh kojima so i went into a
podcast a couple of hours ago i just ran
up here uh i saw it breaking on twitter
though that apparently he has signed
with sony is that right yeah according
to nikkei like one of the biggest
reporting outlets in japan uh he's not
really signed with sony what he has done
is essentially according to the report
made efforts to start his own studio and
is in talks with sony to publish a game
that will come to playstation platforms
first so vita confirmed
right
eventually vita and then morpheus yes
and then did they have some sort of
phone
they did they'd used to have that what
was that was that the erickson
experience the experience was that what
do you call it there's there was the psp
phone oh there was the psp go is that
what it was i think
yeah the phone so many phones there's so
many great sony products we just don't
have enough time to cover them all yeah
on the show this week we'll have to get
that for the next time um what i want to
talk to you guys about is the uh worst
games that came in 2016. oh boy but uh
i'm still waiting for my laptop to
connect to the wi-fi up here let's keep
talking about could you guys keep
talking about it okay so
this report like how
we were waiting for this right because
december was when people were saying his
non-compete was going to that was a
rumor and then that's when we'll hear
trickles come out from somewhere and
does this seem credible
um i mean nikkei hasn't really swung us
wrong in the past so i'm kind of willing
to
willing to go with it what i'm really
interested to see is how much of a coup
he starts when he leaves right when he's
gone like are people going to leave with
him or is he out on his own like i think
that's well at least that's what i'm the
most interested in but if nikkei reports
it i'd say okay yeah yeah i mean i
personally have the opinion that people
like to follow great leaders and kojima
is
known to be a great leader like among
his staff and beyond that any great
games that come out of him are not just
a product of his own hand right it is a
product of a team that works well
together and they have over many years
and uh and i think it would be
silly of him to move on without them i
don't think he would and i think they
would be naive to not leave konami
because it's the safety of a big
corporation because that place does not
care about its employees apparently i
mean especially creative people right
like creative people want to make good
things they want to be able to be led by
somebody who has good creative
leadership and the worst thing they hate
is bureaucracy in companies which force
them to not be creative yeah and that
very much seems like what's happening at
konami right now right yeah like i mean
yeah konami is look they're saying look
we're gonna double down on pachinko
we're gonna double down on mobile like
oh we're still making console games but
they also said kojima was just on
vacation the day after he celebrated his
departure from the company yeah so i
mean i i'm not convinced that they even
have the talent to get back into the
console space at this point beyond
making more pez games but hey man no pez
is fine but but what i'm saying don't
talk
about european representative on the set
here don't talk to me about no pez game
apathy
this year's was good right that's fun
right rob crossy loved it a hell of a
whole bunch yeah oh yeah yeah 9 out of
10 on gamespot.com one of the best
reviewed games on gamespot.com you could
say which is the antithesis of what
we're going to talk about once this
google drive thing loads up here we go
oh [ __ ] it up
i could talk about bad games you want to
talk about bad games i reviewed a lot of
them
let's give me yeah mary's running a
laptop
okay you got my phone i got the list on
my phone you got this on your phone yeah
it's weird did this new thing called a
smartphone you got any apps on that
this year was really bad for smartphones
i have peggle and angry really well what
makes you say that i mean we can't get
into specifics because game of the year
and i don't think we've talked about
that yet
but there wasn't that many
fallout shelter that was is that a game
does that work all right i got it right
here that's a that's a killer app got it
right here this is awesome all right
compelling content folks here we go 2015
fifty
it's 2015.
2015. great year for video games
but there were some bad video games
peter brown reviews editor of
gamespot.com uh you took over the
the the reigns from mr van word earlier
this year uh it turns out there was a
lot of bad games came out and the
the which my favorite part of this is
actually you reviewed quite a lot of
them yeah i think three yeah on that
list real stinkers jesus i have a list
here of all games that got under
five out of ten so four and below on
gamespot.com i can't even talk about all
of them because there are so many of
them uh but let's rattle let's
rattle for a few uh first of all uh a
wonderful three out of ten here tony
hawk's pro skater five peter brown you
reviewed that game why was that game not
better
uh so
there were moments when i was playing
tony hawk 5 where i felt like it it like
captured the essence of the old games
but gaming has moved on
and rather than like change with the
times
and and take you know lessons learned
from years of development after the fact
they sort of just like cobbled together
some weird features and put it on top of
this really really bare tony hawk
experience
and they didn't do it in a clean way
there are a lot of glitches
it's it's
it was broken it wasn't challenging in
the right ways and it just wasn't fun
like after five minutes i was done with
it they didn't give me a reason to
actually care
and
like you know what at this point like
tony hawk is kind of old news like we've
played this style of game many times
over tony hawk hd is still a thing and
better than this game i mean a good tony
hawk game would probably have been
pretty cool to play it would have been
great
hd is a good tony hawk game and this one
sort of it seems like it's kind of good
every now and again like it gives you
shades of what you remember but then
it instantly sort of gives you
look at how do you see how the screen is
shaking when he's grinding like
that is a logical decision somebody made
like that first time that came up i was
like oh that's like a novel little level
and then it comes up like in four
different levels under like slightly
different every stage you go to has the
same challenges
it's just cookie cutter crap
what a shame you kind of glanced over at
your tv it looked really fun but i think
i was just glancing over
as you do very briefly yeah and the the
grind stump thing is like one of the
worst controlled decisions i've seen in
in recent years yeah it got rid of any
ability to like buffer a thing and
actually like make a clean combo in
their mode where you're another game you
reviewed uh around that time as well i
think four out of ten chibi-robo
ziplash
got them i didn't even know what the
hell this is
so you play this little robot uh that
sort of has like a is like a extension
cord used as a grappling hook okay and
so you get through these levels it's
just like a side-scrolling 2d platformer
but the game isn't challenging it's very
easy which isn't necessarily that bad
but the biggest problem i had with the
game is that your sole motivation
is to go out and collect
like actual real world candy okay and
bring it back to people and they're like
boy i sure do love starburst with the
five flavors that really tickle my
tongue really yes this game is filled
with commercials and it is
like okay the gameplay is solid it's not
great it's not challenging but that part
was just stupid
filthy
filthy and another game that came out
relatively recently 4 out of 10 wwe 2k16
have any all played that this year's
version no several minutes at a friend's
house okay how fun was that i'm not too
well versed in wrestling games in
general since like the nintendo 64. but
okay so you're not a scholar of the wwe
universe no it didn't i've only recently
started watching wrestling sort of but
the game it's a real bad time to be
watching for us oh that's what i hear i
think you can only go uphill from here
everyone's injured right now but the
game itself doesn't really feel like
feel great i don't i never knew what i
was doing even when i tried learning
several of the moves and the controls i
know a lot of people i think our review
was complaining about it's kind of
arbitrary how close you need to be
someone
how you actually
like start these moves and it felt
pretty bad
that was pretty cool
it was just walking through a mini big
biggest roster they've had in the game
ever
a pretty low score sadly four to ten on
the on gamespot.com uh a game that got
lower than that though came out i feel
was it in your first devil's third it's
only coming recently
that was a uk reviewer who yeah sean
bell i believe sean bell three out of
ten
i hear that game's a real piece of hot
garbage
yeah it's kind of a tragic story too
because apparently idigaki has been
trying to make this game forever and
it's changed hands multiple times in
terms of publishers and ownership and
you know with that comes different
demands and i mean who knows where the
blame actually lies but yeah this game
did not pan out
jesus here we have ivan right
sick tattoos yeah the most original
character
i mean whoa like what the hell are we
looking at here like this is a wii u
game like
what imagination went into crafting that
character that's what i wanted somebody
saw prison break
also it's a wii u game i feel like at
the end of its life cycle
yeah it's a bit weird that it also got
it was such a massive delay between here
and
europe like it's it's almost so
wonderful yeah they're releasing it at
all
terrible critical reception on a console
that not many people are buying these
types of games especially even nintendo
like when they're sending out press
releases to like or just like you know
like mailing list stuff they remind you
of all the great games that are coming
out like the final paragraph is like oh
yeah if you want to get doubles
it's not even a paragraph it's a bullet
point that like buried it oh no uh
speaking of weird stuff that was
released in europe first uh rory mcilroy
pj tour finally gets the the honors get
away tiger i'm on the box representing
northern ireland three out of ten
apparently this is not a good golf game
i guess not no no
it didn't golf experts
it didn't look great i mean the actual
environments themselves looked pretty
shoddy some gameplay
look at this game
i'd give this game a bogey a golf out of
sports i got it look at that
that guy looks pretty good that what do
you call that guy the caddy the caddy
that the couch master
look at that look will he get it will he
get it will he got it will he get it
golf
three out of ten yeah baseball
game's got everything you're adding uh
conor mcgregor with clc exactly uh a
game that somebody here on the couch has
played a game that was so bad that it's
been pulled from stores afro
two out of ten on gamespot peter just
wow in a game full of hot car and a year
with some hot garbage this may have been
the stinkiest uh it's it's one of the
worst like finished published games i've
ever played uh both on a technical level
on a design level and
just when it comes to just like
oh wait
it was painful watching how you do this
i like
as much screaming as you did during tony
hawk i think maybe this was worse
i just remember watching him review it
and you just were the saddest i've ever
seen
i don't even know where to start like
okay we're not even showing footage yeah
we have to show footage i need i need
like a source we can't because it's
going to give people convulsions okay
afro-samurai is a game
has a combat system
there's three three tiers in its combat
system that offer different fighting
styles none of them matter
like cut scenes end halfway through and
gameplay goes but you still have the
audio from the cutscene going and okay
the audio from the gameplay great uh
there's a scene where you're going to
try to find a man
and the game's justification is where do
you go to find men strip clubs so okay
so there's a strip club that's fine but
the problem is hey when you're in the
strip club it focuses on a woman
oh his breasts are out just swaying back
and forth for like 10 minutes
two minutes later this dude like after
she dies like calls her a [ __ ] and it's
like oh my god like what is what is this
this game has nothing going for it it
sounds like what era did this game come
out
it's horrible i mean i
and because the bad checkpoints did you
have to redo that scene like four times
i had to redo that
multiple times because there was a boss
fight that didn't actually just describe
how like what the rules were yeah so i
didn't know so i was beating my head
against the wall for oh jesus okay
good all right right they they set up
this like huge town they do this huge
flyby and they're like oh man like i'm
gonna have to go explore and then they
put you right at the doorstep of the
place you need to get to like this is a
game of unrealized ideas like unrefined
writing
poor acting
the best thing it has is a soundtrack
that is oh yeah somewhat enjoyable and
it's a real shame so soak it in kids
because this is the only way you'll be
able to play experience afro sunrise too
it's not available anymore uh kevin van
our before he left us for greener
pastures three out of ten godzilla
wow yeah that game is trash
uh to quote a to quote a peter brown is
ism it is a trash game for garbage
people
garbage game for two garbage game for
trash people whatever
what a shame it's bad
it's bad it's like
yeah you're supposed to be just cause
three basically right you're just like
you're just destroying you're destroying
the city and like you know how it stops
and it stops and it stops yeah that's
part of the gameplay and they they put
that in on purpose so they could
recreate like the feel of the tv show
okay where things would slow down but
instead of being like
entertaining it's just super frustrating
you have to walk long distances as well
is this like lumbering yeah oh look at
that try again can't call an uber right
here
he moves so slow
it's so bad look at him look at this
look at this yeah just we don't even
need us to talk just watch this pile of
garbage here we go that guy in the top
right hand corner he's not even animated
look at that thing it's a metal godzilla
speaking of weird uh games based around
carnage uh we finally got to play
carmageddon reincarnation cameron
woolsey uh reviewed her first four out
of ten has anyone played that one beta
yeah it's a technical mess
but that's a beta for you i don't know
what what did he say do you remember
nope sure don't similar in these games
like twisted metal
or vigilante no they're not like car
arena battlers like they are they're
what is going on clearly okay still a
technical mess
you know these are just racing games
that like you know like the original
came out like in the early 90s and it
was all bloody and dark okay cool let's
bring it back okay oh my gosh
a real shame because i love some of
these old classic games and like some of
them should remain classic kind of like
this is a great game to come back but
then just bad excuse like there's like
road rashes
oh god yeah there you go go what's going
to happen
this is an official trailer i think this
is so weird the penguins
almost had
to get through i got three more here uh
austin walker before he joined giant
bomb reviewed a bunch of game for us uh
he really liked project cars he was not
so much fun of code names oh my god
screw that game four out of ten i hate
that game they announced it like only
the e3 previous like it came out like
nine months later yeah they had like a
big special special presentation where
they were like we're going to announce
our new game and it was codenamed steam
and what's so disappointing about
codename steam is it is a strategy like
tactical turn-based game by the fire
emblem people yeah the fire emblem games
are so good and codeine team was such
garbage and the whole idea of like the
american heroes teaming up was kind of
cool like abraham lincoln like running
running like a like this is like
underground steampunk mafia or whatever
it was sounded cool but some of the
characters also really overtly racist
and the gameplay real bad yeah yeah
it tried to be like an x-com light for
kids yeah no and and
it's yeah like it was slow
it didn't
the yeah the themes
like the themes in the artwork were just
immediately off-putting to me and the
gameplay added added no value it's and
it is a shame
like it and it's just it's like curious
footnote in the last year for nintendo
like no one talks about it anymore yeah
they made such a big deal about it and
just quietly
yeah and they had to do like a patch for
it because like the turns were too slow
yes i remember that you're right it was
like this big deal because the enemy
enemy turns to took too long so you
could speed it up like just a mess just
a technical mess uh the lowest scoring
game on gamespot.com uh was earlier this
year don sauce with raven's cry yeah
remember that sex yeah i remember
reading something
the thing that stood out to me was the
fact that you had to press the x button
like multiple times to open a door
like like it like it was just riddled
with illogical mechanics yeah it's a bit
stuck you gotta really you gotta really
jam on that button i mean this this
looks nice right
but
you said it was sexist alexa um so i
previewed the game a couple years ago
and i remember seeing it when it came
out it's just really like gross and like
overtly sexual and like it doesn't even
do it in like a way that's like
that's like
can like to the plot or to the character
development it's just there to be there
and i think it's just i remember don's
review actually highlighted that pretty
yeah as well and just technical problems
around and just not like just incredibly
uninteresting yeah i ran the whole way
so it's no black flag
it's no black flag no if you want to
play your pirate game you got it uh
ravens cry there one out of ten on
gamespot.com the last one to mention
this year
yowza i feel like this game would get an
even worse score if it came out today
justin clark reviewed hatred
that's three out of ten almost at 10 at
a time
postal clone um i used to like old
postal games i used to play they were
kind of like dumb games when i was a kid
this is like a poor version of that
which is that
also
i don't know just was like super gross
and
you know it's incredibly gross yeah
considering everything that's happened
this year with like
mass shootings and like violence and
stuff i just feel like this game was
like as bad a reception as it got back
in whatever it was june or something
could be worse today like you got to say
that they're probably not going to be
making a sequel to this bad boy anytime
soon
distance from it i never touched it yeah
i think i it kind of came out to a bit
of a whimper i think well a lot of
people played us some people were
talking about not covering it and
covering it but ultimately like you know
the game just it's it's all you know
it's all teeth and no bite really well
and you hear people like sort of
defending like the game place you know
the gameplay is sound like it actually
is like a decent logo and it's like well
you know what like there are so many
other games that are good and worth your
time why the hell would you support
something as hateful and disgusting as
this game like this is a game about mass
murder for the sake of retribution
against strangers [ __ ] that let's stop
showing footage of it how about that
worst games that came out this year uh
but let's go down the the couch and say
what was our favorite worst game or what
was the game that was the worst to you
personally favorite worst like the most
disappointing worst game flatter worst
game i'm gonna stick with codename steam
because i adore the fire emblem games
and i had such high hopes when i heard
that intelligent systems was making
something like like another tactical
thing like fire emblem but not fire
emblem and i was just the most
disappointed i've ever been i think mike
what do you think although devil's third
just because i think of the bad games
that's the one i spent the most time
with and by that i mean
75 minutes or something but i remember
just thinking to myself maybe they're
trying to be this bad but i don't think
that was a case especially considering
nintendo's kind of brushing it under the
rug afterward or like devil's turd nice
thank you i've never heard that joke
before
peter what's yours uh afro samurai 2
it's uh it's a very ignorant game and
it's poorly made and it never should
have been brought to market and uh
sorry guys well there won't be any
sequels now i know thank god you know
what a gamer probably will get a sequel
that i was super disappointed about tony
hawk sports gator five
do you think it will
yeah i think they're going to keep
making skateboard games and i think tony
hawk is going to be still a name in
like i think he's still the mo he will
be the most recognizable skateboarder 10
years from now oh that like you know
colin mcrae wasn't the most recognizable
like
sports person in the world but that name
still had clout within the genre of
rally you know what game has real clout
within the skateboarding community what
skate yeah i love skate i love skate
that is a game that should come back
activision love
bringing back a franchise though so yeah
i don't know we'll see
plenty of awful games to talk about this
year what a shame of course our game
spot game of the year awards are on
which is the opposite of this make sure
you check out the site to see what we
think of our best games that came out in
2015 and let us know in the comments
what you thought were the worst games
your personal worst game that came out
in 2015. all right we got a bunch more
stuff to talk about in the show i want
to let people know that we got a final
segment today which is all about the
game that we played the longest our
friends at duracell have asked us to
sort of uh pick through the games we
played and then explain which is the one
that we
couldn't put the controller there for us
we're going to do that the last section
on the side but you can also get
involved as well if you're on twitter
use hashtag duracell sweeps
and then also we're going to have a
little competition at the end of the
show
so make sure you're watching then for a
chance to win 10 of the best games that
come out this year duracell sweeps
hashtag yourself sweeps i'm keeping an
eye out here on my laptop uh let us know
what was the game that you personally
could not put down and we'll put it to
our panel as well uh we'll be back in
just a second we got a trailer for
unravel this game looks pretty coming in
2016. let's check it out
uh
2015 was a wonderful year for video
games and if you are like me you're
already looking forward to january and
all the games that are going to come out
in 2016 peter brown mike mccarty alexa
ray korea let's go through it let's get
2016 hype are you hype yes are you hyped
mike yeah you're always hype i am that's
my thing peter brown let's not get ahead
of ourselves here okay okay
about i'm just a cynical peter tantalize
you with this one how about
xcom 2. come on february
excited for that let's not get ahead of
ourselves here
i actually am not a huge xcom fan so uh
i mean i'm i'm glad to see that game is
coming back and people are excited for
it yeah and the batman went off and
played a bunch of it last week i think
i'm so excited for next time too i'm
extremely excited for xm2 i'm not going
to be telling you why
so uh
enemy unknown and enemy within both
unreal like this blend of just squad
tactics and overall strategy i'm playing
with it right now on the ipod yeah yeah
oh and the memory is so good and i'm
just really excited for like more units
more enemies it's kind of this cool new
take on the world where it's 20 years
after and the aliens have already won so
you're more of a rebellion than an
actual like defense force yeah and you
there's so many small things that i'm
really excited about you can carry squad
mates when they're wounded you can carry
them when they're dead and you just need
their gear which is pretty morbid but i
mean it still has another layer but you
can also like when you go into some
missions you're in stealth as opposed to
automatic like the aliens knowing where
you are so you kind of complete
objectives theoretically just without
them knowing you were there um and i'm a
big fan of stealth and xcom so kind of
blending those two seems pretty
appealing to me overall it just sounds
like
you know if they take what made the
first games great and make it better
that should be awesome yeah um we've
seen i guess a lot of people that sort
of moba genre expand out into different
genres and next year is kind of when the
first person moba chickens will come
home to roost we're going to have
overwatch and battleborn within the
first half of the year yeah hero
shooters hero shooters any any takers
for either of those games because they
are kind of going up against each other
in a way although one of
the consoles you
both pc now as well
i've played a little bit of both and
like i hate mobas because mobas are for
nerds so
i uh i played a little final fantasy
i played i played a little a little bit
of both i played them at events and i uh
overwatch
i really like the style of overwatch and
i really like the setup of overwatch
however like i don't know what i'm doing
going into those games so when i was
playing at events i would get sniped the
second i walked out so that needs some
balancing optimistic i think that's a
kind of an event problem is that you
have absolutely because we played at
blizzcon and myself eric tay and andy
bauman just smoked everyone because we
were playing as a team because we were
there together um i've i have played so
much overwatch like it's weird we're
talking about like the best first-person
shooters that came out this year we
played this year this is the best fps
update this year it's just not
officially out yet because that alpha
was pretty uh pretty it wasn't it was
pretty closed and so i'm really excited
for this yeah no overwatch is great but
with uh battleborn so i played i think a
lot of what makes battleborn charming is
the character thing like i think
battleborn is gonna be the game for
people that like to latch onto a
character and play a game because of a
character whereas overwatch will be the
game for people that want that
hero shooter
i i've warmed to the characters no watch
more as well maybe because i haven't
played much battleborn there seems to be
more of it like blizzard are so good at
that in a way that i don't know this
seems to be so disparate with like
mushroom
dude and you know some of them are the
penguin in the match
okay the penguin is pretty cool
especially because rob henry does the
voice for it
has anyone played battleborn yes yeah
what do you think uh we got to play some
of the co-op campaigns something i guess
they're saying it's story driven but
that even that's pretty bare bone but in
general yeah it seems they're it's
definitely going for the same thing as
overwatch and i guess battle cry to some
extent but oh yeah
but that's been pushed back as well
right it's a it's a cool concept i mean
in terms of this if you want a story out
of these games which isn't like a huge
drawing force but you know like there's
one more star in the galaxy everybody's
converging on but it really i mean this
is nico they're using right now the
mushroom guy you mentioned and his kind
of he's more of a support character and
he can heal but i i don't know i it's
still got that whole you know different
characters the different abilities that
you can kind of experiment with i could
see myself putting a few hours into it
it's going to be interesting to see
which one of those sort of rises to the
top a game that has a story that people
are very interested in uh march 18th
we're going to finally get uncharted 4.
a thief sent any takers for that one
yeah i love everything thai root does so
nightmare times yeah what is what is the
deal with the with the what is that what
is the deal
with
with the choosing the branching like the
storyline stuff that like that's
probably just like pretty surface level
right yeah well we have no idea i'm sure
they're going to flick a switch after
that like what a way to test an audience
by giving them like that little taste
and seeing how people react to it right
maybe nobody wants that they could
easily just turn it off if it was a
thing yeah i don't think anybody wants
it it just doesn't make sense to me like
these games seems seem to be they don't
need it they don't they're roller
coasters that that you know when you
play a part it's in a sequence that is
like action-packed it's not during this
like moment where you're trying to make
a poignant decision with your brother
who you haven't seen in 10 years like
what what game is that that's not
uncharted
ride the roller coaster you don't want
to be the guy pulling the lever
i'm really interested to see how this
game shakes out because the original
writer is no longer oh yeah working on
the series amy heading left and now
she's working on a star wars game and uh
i don't know i feel like i feel like if
she was around maybe the dialogue
choices wouldn't be a thing so i'm sort
of cautiously optimistic like i'm going
to play it cause it's an uncharted's
been a great series but i do think maybe
story-wise
yeah we'll see two drakes this time
around the game
dracai i think is what we call them a
game that we haven't seen much of uh a
little bit at e3 which definitely sort
of got the taste buds of watering june
2016 recore peter brown excited for that
yeah i uh i like things that kg nafuni
does he tends to doing a lot of them at
the moment he's doing a lot of them at
the moment he's also a very
misunderstood guy
rather than focus on the controversy
surrounding his other projects uh this
is one that is really interesting to me
because not only is it a cajun foodie
joint it is an armature studios joint
and the that studio is run by a lot of
guys who used to work on metroid prime
right which is one of my favorite like
little like mini series of all time and
uh you know it it's interesting because
it sort of does the mega man thing in
that one of the characters can kind of
transform and have different abilities
in this case by being implanted into
something rather than like taking on a
thing but uh but yeah like we still
don't know too much about it
but i'm willing to sort of be on you
know for a change optimistic yeah we'll
see look at those people on the couch
they're different to the people on the
couch right now it's the same couch
though uh getting out we've got a bunch
more games so let's rush through a
couple more uh doom we will see
maybe next year that's a first person
shooter yeah it's software i'm making
good luck to them hopefully that'll be
cool and really really russian this here
is great i play multiplayer yes yeah
many people have there was an open beta
recently is it like it's like quick okay
it's really fast and it's really fun and
i had sort of given up on doom during
the e3 presentation but when i went to
quakecon and played the multiplayer
total bad face maybe i don't care about
the campaign but that multiplayer is
awesome great there you go multiplayer
in a doom game is your review
no man's sky didn't come in 2015
apparently coming out like the week of
e3 or something yeah that's going to be
a nightmare for them um yeah looking
forward to that one on the couch yeah it
is a crazy experiment that i think
will
i i'll be curious to see the long-term
benefits of what they're trying to do
and how the community latches on to it
um because they're supposed to be like
64 quin you know eighteen quintillion
planets yeah in this year we will never
ever get anywhere close to like finding
one percent oh no of course not but like
but the method in which that you know
they're creating all of these things
is kind of obvious but also ingenious in
the way they've implemented it and then
you add on this sort of seamless
transition from space to terra firma
like it's this
it's the definitive open world game i
can't think of a game that tries to
tackle that
at such a scale any better than this
yeah even if the sort of the gameplay is
going to be relatively restrictive as it
seems to be you know it seems to be a
pretty you know you go out mine for
stuff upgrade your ship so you can
explore further like we'll see how many
legs that has like just as a concept it
seems like it's going to be so much fun
especially now that a girl has made it
all the way back to earth
is finished
like it's it's finally i love you call
it not be knobby boy what's your nobody
know me boy nobody nobody no we know me
boy i prefer nobody knows for obvious
reasons
i prefer
another game that we're dying to play
which we saw more obviously literally
dying dying the last guardian yeah
seriously yeah yeah that [ __ ] out there
that's great glass of paint on it yes
it's i still know nothing about what it
is going to be a you know
puzzle platformer with a big old dog
looking thing a boy is a griffin kind of
thing and his
awkward eco but instead of a little girl
it's this
disaster little boy look at him oh he's
still cute looking but he's going to get
you killed he's also going to die at
some point oh yeah yeah i know he's good
oh my god
top picks for 2016 characters who die is
nathan drake's brother and this thing
but what if it dies and then from its
core corpse emerges a baby version of
itself and the cycle of life begins new
year
and you lift it up in the sky like a
phoenix
i hope that's not it like i really hope
he doesn't
die
i really hope that's not what this is
setting up go
the last guardian that's why there's not
a baby what if they ascend to heaven
together
assuming there is a heaven let's not get
heavy here okay it's a video game
a game that is getting into some pretty
deep uh topics though which hopefully
we'll play next year is cuphead
oh yeah oh yeah yeah themes of the
struggle of classes
have you guys played
no i've i've only watched it but that's
enough for me to want to play
it's really oh really
i finally played it at pax and i
remember it took me a while to like even
get my head around the fact that it was
here yeah we did it was more of a contra
than it was anyway
yeah yeah you know between crouching and
actually the bosses it's all just
possible
yeah and you're going between these each
boss and i was trying to find the
easiest one during the demo and none of
them were and apparently i suck at it
but maybe i'll get better looking
forward it was fun but it just it's it's
beautiful too they've done an amazing
job
hand drawn right correct yeah
i worry the accessibility is going to
become an issue and that game might not
do so hot uh on the multiplayer space
side of things for honor that look
interesting i think it was fun yeah i
think it was fun as heck does it play
like chivalry at all around like that or
is it easier to control or because it's
the same kind of like yeah yeah there's
like the three you have like the
triangle so like there's a top and a
side and a side and you can block or hit
or whatever and it's uh one of those
games where you sort of have to be on a
headset talking to someone right like i
played at pax with a friend and we were
in a team of four and she and i had each
other in the headsets and we're like
okay you capture you have to capture
areas and defend them while also
capturing new areas so it's like all
right you stay in and you stay and
defend this i'm gonna go capture and
then she'd be like i need backup and i
would go and then she'd switch out like
you really have to communicate with the
people on your team which i actually
really like that it's it sort of
simplifies that and simplifies the
amount of actions that you need to do
but it's really fun i really like it
also it looks really pretty so it's like
multiplayer dynasty warriors then yeah
it's like multiplayer dynasty warriors
without the dynasty warriors it's weird
because like there seems to be like i
feel like there's been a bunch of these
games flying around on steam for the
past five years but this is the first
time somebody would like triple a
pedigree has really taken a swing at it
get it anyway it was a lot of fun it
handles really well uh horizon zero dawn
there's a game that we didn't really
know much about and then people got
super excited about uh delighted that
gorilla are making something other than
killzone yes
looks great it looks like
far cry third person with dinosaurs and
some weird cyberpunk aspects so there's
a far cry
so it's parkour primal the new like a
newer fighter are there different
stories
no
probably right they're raptors there's
probably one in there somewhere this is
this is such a weird blend like you see
her and you assume it's going to be some
sort of like even i don't know like you
said far cry primal but then the
dinosaurs themselves are made out of
like some sort of machinery you know the
robots match
what i'm worried about with this game is
that they've shown it off like a couple
times e3 being the biggest when it was
revealed every demo they show takes
place in the same little area yeah with
them approaching this enemy in a
different way and that's well and good
and proves that the system works
but
there's got is there not something more
tantalizing that they can show us it's
usually not a good sign when the best
thing you have is like one vertical
slice and you iterate upon that for
months on end in terms of you know in
the public eye yeah like fingers crossed
we'll see a lot more of this before i
hope so it comes out
it's the final fantasy 15 approach
there you go you showed the same
vertical slice over and over delicious
when the slice tastes that good uh
speaking of wild lands ghost recon
wildlands may be coming out next year as
well
what is he talking about
that was the show complete surprise at
e3 right yeah there's nothing
like open world ghost recon open world
third person ghost recon and you you're
taking down the cartel and you can kind
of decide whether to get they showed the
same demo well sorry the same area twice
how did i miss this once they went in
like i had a sniper up here and it's
like stealthily kind of extracted the
guy they're going for the next they went
and just guns blazing brought it out
like a jeep i mean it doesn't sound like
it's anything crazy new but if they can
kind of use like ghost recon is always
really controlled well shoot that guy
he's like multiplayer he looks like he
sells drugs right yeah that's a good
comparison it's kind of like what you
could do in metal gear i guess if you're
being stealthy or it's just if you don't
want to be stealthy look at it it's
great i don't know you have to kill drug
lords you get to maybe take some drugs
in a brown truck doesn't know how to
drive properly because he's on drugs
looking for because it causes the drugs
a game we haven't seen much of at all
and fingers crossed is either getting
delayed for a new console or it's just
taking long the new zelda game will we
see that next year will it be on the nx
i'm willing to bet that it will be on
both well actually
twilight princess that's a pretty safe
bet i mean it's a safe bet but like if
we also believe that recent patent that
got out that nintendo engineers names
were attached to for the new controller
yeah you have to imagine anything
nintendo's doing well
especially a game as big as this take
advantage of that right they've done it
with the gamepad for the wii u
so i'm curious if they're actually going
to retool it just for the nx
but then also put it on wii u i mean i
suppose they could and just not go too
deep into that new controller and all
those weird aspects i might introduce
but but yeah i think this game is going
to come out regardless of the platform
next year for sure fingers crossed thing
yeah
on the same sort of nintendo front
kingdom hearts three as well
same nintendo first nintendo oh yeah i
don't know dude
japanese games front we are not getting
this game
for like two years this game is not
coming out next year 100
no absolutely not they have one more
prequel game coming out kingdom hearts
2.8 final chapter prologue barf which
has to come out next oh nintendo
nintendo
um so this game is like they're still
announcing worlds they've barely shown
us much of what's going on this game is
2017 at the earliest it's not coming out
next year especially with final fantasy
15 they're not going to blow their two
big jrpg loads in one year absolutely
not don't blow your load you know it's
blowing their loads i apologize for
saying that x and xbox are gonna blow
three loads on us next year i've got
them right here they're our final three
games
on my list so sorry first of all
who's excited for gears of four
sure yay
yes yeah good series i know mary kish is
excited for it mary's excited there
going on two characters so i don't have
a clue where they are i'm intrigued i
don't know it just looks so weird look
at this thing it's like a [ __ ]
mongoose
you gotta shoot it shoot it why are you
looking at it shoot it you dumbass what
kind of mongooses do they have in
ireland
manga i don't know we'll hopefully it'll
be good it'll be a cover shooter they're
real hot
peter scowling it's like bloodborne but
with gears of war and no lights
i'm so sick of old ips oh really
well then well then microsoft's other
two loads are new ips the first one from
the good people at remedy it's a quantum
break
why'd you say it like that that's how he
speaks
remedy man
similarly i'm like yeah
quantum break
and this is a quantum bracket it's weird
because initially i thought it was
actually going to use time mechanics
more than it looks now it looks more
it's kind of like bullet time from max
payne but then just really fast body
slam dashes yeah um press x to body
slam-dunk yeah
the tv show has been rolled back so now
it's on the disc it's got just a good
thing probably iceman bobby drake
he's in it now or he's always been in it
i guess but he's still in it and he's
spreading through time littlefinger's
the bad guy apparently oh yeah
little finger travel through time to
beat the villain yeah it's in the same
universe as game of thrones
and then the final load my good friends
microsoft you made your best i'm so
sorry
is uh crack 10 yeah yeah you know the
most exciting thing about crackdown is
the stuff they're doing with the cloud
mm-hmm like yes it's let's try finally
in the game
no more not another
nintendo this is the one game that has
finally proven to me and it was great it
was only in an isolated demo microsoft
said it was like real world scenario
where
like we don't have there's there's not
going to be a next gen that we care
about right this game is introducing a
thing where you have the power of like
25 xbox ones you know from multiple
servers coming together and it proves
itself when you watch entire buildings
like huge cityscapes crumble without the
game skipping a beat like yeah just
cause three can do some stuff that's
pretty cool this game is like
that times ten it is insane but the
regular game i don't know
it'll be fun for a while right if they
do it well with the spot and everything
maybe i mean well the cloud stuff is
only gonna be multiplayer it's not going
to have to do anything with the single
player game and i love the original
crackdown the second one just seemed to
iterate on it with no real added value
i don't know what they're going to do to
make this yeah
something new right if it's just more of
the same
i was saying a minute ago i'm tired of
more of the same yeah i guess we'll have
to wait and find out 2016 is when that's
coming out i'm sure i've forgotten a
couple first one that comes to mind
actually is the division hopefully we'll
see that next year as well sorry about
that maybe soft need to get that out
maybe then they've hadn't haven't had
great success with new ip with watch
dogs hopefully this will be a great new
addition to their slate uh anything else
that you guys can think of that i didn't
mention i'm sure talk about final
fantasy 15. final fantasy 15
yeah i didn't talk about it we didn't
talk about those nintendo games
god i can't believe danny thinks that
final fantasy is a nintendo game i think
disney's nintendo does that what
happened they bought disney they're
basic they're sure eventually disney
will buy everything yeah that will
consume us all mary you shouted sonic
division i said the division the
division good shot
good job dark souls dark souls 3 oh dark
souls
3
from what i played it's really fun it
looks like they're kind of bringing a
little more bloodborne into dark souls
but also keeping the franchise separate
yeah which is great because i know
people who are souls fans that don't
like bloodborne and vice versa i myself
like both so i'm kind of happy to see
them melting into one another a little
bit as long as it still feels like a
dark souls game which it does so far i
haven't even mentioned madden 16
fifa 16
new four it's a game right they're on
annual
fire emblem fates is gonna be good fire
emblem fates so many games coming out in
2016. firewatch firewatch deus ex nobody
knows what this is going to be good fire
watch i played it it's like gone home
only you're an older sad guy and you do
stuff and you yeah instead of just
looking around
i like it what's the way what's the
exclusive pre-order bonus though
another older sad guy i don't know
so many great games coming back 2016. we
don't have time for any more let us know
what your favorite game was uh of uh
2016 what are you most looking forward
to your most anticipated game rather i
should say in the comment box below
alright we'll be back in a second we're
going to talk about the games we most
played in 2015 uh but first of all mary
kish put together a wonderful video
about our move you may have noticed that
we are currently in the cent studios
thank you so much to our friends at cena
for allowing us to great look at that
look at that that's not about it kind of
looks like it's fake it does look like
it's fake it's anything really
it's not there is real building real web
2.0 [ __ ] happening out there the bridge
in the back
2.0 gentrification but we were we've
been up here and we moved office from
the bottom floor of the first floor
sorry from the third floor to the bottom
floor of this building uh and that was a
floor that gamespot was on for 14 years
14 years
crazy yeah so if you watched old on the
spot or all the way back to rich gallop
stuff anything between that and that was
all done
on that floor so back when jeff had
bleached hair yes
back before they were born
14 years ago
it's amazing you have that beard i was
gonna say yeah but there's that trt or
whatever you're using it testosterone
sure yeah so yeah we spent a lot of time
on that floor and obviously a very
saturday so may put together this little
montage of us getting the hell out of
there let's check it out
the end of our offices as we know it
danny your desk is so empty nothing's
labeled
i'm glad i see nose ever again
except this showstopper
your desk looks a little empty
yeah except for all these goddamn
oktoberfest glasses looks like you're
keeping all of your glassware oh my god
you're going to take those carrots
and carrots i think i'm going to hang
out with carrots
more mileage out of them those are good
carrots
trucking
up all these games can you imagine they
actually the game for a laptop specific
what are these oh those are all mega man
sound like the hedgehog comics god
micah
someone's office
you can't just walk into my house
i didn't know you were promoted
congratulations
it's been drinking beers well it says 98
l what a pizza
do
thanks so much for putting that together
and thanks to everyone who helped us
move from the third floor to the first
floor and indeed everyone who's helping
uh put together our new lobby set which
will be kicking off in february we're
gonna take a month off in january to get
it all working we'll have a bunch of
stuff on the side to fill that gap in
terms of news and whatnot uh but yeah we
got a lot of building to do do you miss
anything about the third floor
particularly apart from the memories
apart from the memories
you had a room full of game
technology
no i mean it the memories are the
hardest thing to walk away from i mean i
i've been a game spot for years which
pales in comparison to people you know
some people have been here for a lot
longer than that
but uh you know it you the stains on the
carpet the chips on the desks they they
are a product of gamespot's growth
you know uh not as a business but just
as a place where people come together to
make great stuff and communicate with
fans and you know we're starting fresh
as i was talking to jeff about it
yesterday and he's like someone needs to
break something somebody needs to die in
this floor
somehow we have to like break it in
uh and i missed that broken in feeling i
guess uh the feeling of it being
established and having history so
you know history begins a new here
and uh and uh yeah i look forward to
seeing what we do i think we're gonna do
great stuff and hopefully this this move
is a a good kick start yeah for sure i
feel the same way it's being able to
like walk past where the time trotters
room was and like sit on the same set
that was there when i was in ireland
watching yeah [ __ ] all those years
ago was like really special but it is
also nice to kind of sometimes you need
to like cut and run right you need to
like stop like thinking about the way
things were and like think okay what is
this site now and how do we sort of like
best service people right and it's yeah
i mean for all the sad things that come
along with it it's a great opportunity
to really focus and nail what's
important to us what do we really care
about
and to do that you do have to sacrifice
something yeah what about you guys uh
here's slightly shorter than us
but some good memories from uh from the
third floor well i moved in i came well
i started last november and the first
thing that like randy said to me was
like we're moving next year so like
don't get comfortable
um i miss the brown floor
i miss sitting next to that used to be
white it's just
brown don't sit next to peter anymore
sit next to mike
we're still figuring that out we're
still figuring that out to work in
progress
um it's very bright it's super i love it
right now yeah um
i guess i kind of missed the
coming in the morning when it was dark
and a little bit dingy and it was like i
can be in this game cave and now it's
sort of this like sterile white open
like i agree with jeff we need to like
either you know smear crap all over the
floor or like break something or like
just let's payday beers on thursday so
mike you're the newest one at least in
terms of who's on the couch so maybe you
can just smash a bottle of patties oh i
can break things yeah just say the word
is there anything on this set that we
don't need no i'm just kidding this
isn't our set no this isn't our set
sorry man
perp again just uh if you've seen this
man
it's ruined my middle name we've talked
about this yeah yeah that was that was
like could you do the tilt that was
almost marcus phoenix
business can you can you say like anya
uh
anya
there you go mike hardy oh my gosh
never cut away
yeah that's it
wonderful but yeah
i've been here five months i'm gonna
that was too good i sort of missed the
third floor yeah but i'll uh
not as much as pete or you or alexa
that's all right it's not a
mis-measuring contest
pete one not brown over here just trying
no i'm just kidding
uh because he's one helping us or
because he used to look it's a running
joke
i used to work there and my psn name is
pbrown one up and i'm just
so add him i love getting extra lives
anyway this has been a long show but
we've got one uh more segment left uh
our friends over at duracell have
challenged us to think about the games
that we played the most in 2015. those
games that
forced us to not go to the bathroom and
get extra snacks that surround myself in
pringles and whatnot i'm gonna have to
think and then go to the bathroom in the
pringles exactly yes
duracell quantum batteries into your
controller so you keep on playing and i
got my three friends here at lexus korea
mike m hardy
and peter brand talk about the games
that they played the most this year i've
also got a bunch of great uh input from
you guys hashtag duracell sweeps if you
want to get the game you played the most
in on the discussion and stay tuned
because at the end of this segment we're
going to give you details on how to win
the top 10 games that came out this year
as decided by us what are they i don't
know
well i do but i didn't i'm not telling
you
anyway first up uh before we get to the
user suggestions alexa ray korea hi
first game the game you played the most
in 2015 so i didn't play this game the
most in terms of i would sit down and
marathon it but it was the game that i
came back consistently to every day
uh bloodborne okay so when i had like a
crappy day i would come home and i'd put
in bloodborne and i would kill some
things
if i had like a really bummer day i'd go
home and like play bloodborne if i was
angry at someone i'd come home and i'd
blow up someone's place
yeah i come home and i play bloodborne i
just i get a pig i played it i finished
it and then i came back and i did a new
game plus and i have been playing it
sort of a little bit
like
over the past couple months and like on
like a friday night when like all my
friends are out partying and i'm an old
person so i like to be home in bed at
like 9 00 p.m i'm like you know what i'm
gonna say i'm gonna i'm gonna make some
tea and i'm gonna play bloodborne yeah
so i just played one for hours and i
sort of found a lot of i felt like i was
improving as i was playing it and it's
the one game i played this year that
really made me feel like i was
accomplishing something because i was
just overcoming all of this like
gruesome crappy beasts so
i just i sort of settled into it like a
nice comfy couch excellent again a lot
of people in the office have uh have
enjoyed maybe it's in the top 10 games
who knows what we do but we can't tell
you uh that'll be on gamespot.com soon
enough uh just going into the tweets
here uh here's a great one that i know a
lot of people i have to say this one
because i know a lot of people
especially in production are going to
agree with this uh john gaudio says the
game i played the most this year was
destiny the taken king oh i thought
you're going to see rocket league
excuse me
yeah a lot of destiny fans here in the
office taking game obviously was a a big
thing for them as well really improved
that game mike you like those games but
that's not what you picked it's not what
i picked i picked uh afro no uh
sorry the witcher 3 um
i didn't until you know i read kevin's
review and i saw it getting really
positive reviews across the board i plan
on playing it anyway despite the fact
that i really play the first two yeah
but as soon as i got into it it's this
it's unique fantasy setting and like
it's got its own weird creatures it's
got its own very vivid world like
convincing characters it was one of the
first rpgs in a while i've played where
i wasn't completing quests just for
experience or new gear i was completing
questions because i felt like they were
worthwhile and it told a great
overarching story and the main quest had
you know a great structure you'd build
up to this one point where everybody
thought it was the end yes then there
was like eight hours after that and that
was also really good ending yeah
especially those last two three hours
yeah crazy definitely and but just all
these like
smaller side stories that you're like on
the periphery of the game itself that
you come across and these characters you
meet it ranges from like funny to really
sad to really just kind of ominous at a
lot of points and i kept playing it
because i went back in knowing there was
something i was going to find that was
just going to push me through another
you know half hour hour and a half two
hours that i'm just really enjoying
despite the fact that i might not even
be getting experience for it how many
hours do you think you played
um i'd say close to i'd say in the 90s
okay cool yeah because i and then hearts
of stone came out so i went back to play
that and then i played another like 10
hours of the game itself and then now
with um
blood and wine yeah out next year which
is double the size of hearts of stone
entirely new area i'm sure i'll put at
least another
30 into it at least game that keeps on
giving
i got some great tweets coming in here
uh hashtag duracell sweeps uh this might
be my favorite so far uh gadget file
says 569 hours and counting clicker
heroes
no way
like that cookie clicker man it's like
those clicker games you just let them go
just go on holidays go on vacation was
great does that tell you how many hours
you played i'm sure it doesn't
has a timer probably shouldn't though no
yeah i think cookie clicker did as well
when i used to play that another one
great here uh mama bear coach 68. didn't
get that 69. see uh 3 000 errors in gta
5. that seems a bit ridiculous
on pc this year so
that counts peter brown what is the game
you played the most that three thousand
hours i know that's a bit wow
games man
you know i think i put the most hours
into xenoblade chronicles x because
that's a very long game that i had to
finish but
the game that i elected to play the most
was the phantom pain
um i think i played about 50 hours for
the review
um i've probably put in close to 80 i'd
say at this point
i it you know i don't know i feel like
i'm always repeating myself when i talk
about this game
the
the control you have over snake
it's it's cumbersome at first because
the controls are a little bit
complicated but once it clicks it is
like it was surreal how smooth
everything felt to me like i didn't feel
as much i was like controlling a video
game character as i was
willing him to do my bidding without
much thought like it just it felt so
good to do all the things that he could
do and then like bring in all these
vehicles and you know the world like
like 99 of it you can interact with in a
way that that is meaningful to how you
approach a mission um
but you know what what really really got
me into the game was some of the amazing
like uh
i hate to say it but the visuals the
cinematography the the melodrama that
came with the cut scenes i mean i'm
gonna play this game anyway one cause i
have to review it but too because i like
metal gear but it's astounding like the
opening to this game is
and i hate to do it but you compare it
to something like the witcher the
opening yeah dude i'll take a nap like
this thing was it was it was crazy and
it just kept on going with the story
stuff after the fact i had all these
great things to unlock everyone in the
world has sort of adjusted to my
strategies they've gotten used to my
tactics so i have to adjust and
constantly evolve to be effective and
the things i didn't unlock then became
harder to unlock and the game just kept
challenging me in new ways
it's always a good sign of a game where
you want to repeat missions and see what
it looks like a different way
yeah and although this game forces you
sort of to do it
later on in the game like i certainly
enjoyed doing that a lot when i was
playing this like yeah if you took
yourself out of the linearity of the
experience you were just like this is a
stealth challenge right
there's some really great stuff in there
that it made you do this gameplay is
great whoever's playing just is
determined to carry this dude out here
false in her bus
holton or gtfo another great game
mentioned here uh james ackerman says
fallout 4 currently 210 hours uh jesus
yeah that's that's pretty good that's
like how much i put into three total i
think oh really yeah yeah that's a lot
that's a game i feel like i'm going to
be playing for a lot of 2016 as well i
think i played that like 70 hours as
well yeah i reviewed a lot of long video
games this year peter yeah xander blades
metal gear
fallout which is the only one you need
to dive into over your christmas break
yeah i haven't played as much of that as
i'd like and that's probably the game
that i would pick in terms of
time i think i'm if i add up my xbox one
and pc i think i'm around the 200 hours
on which or now i've played it boat
loaded up but since you already talked
about it i would have to go for rocket
league just purely out of the fact that
it's a game that we've played so much in
the office like a game that we have made
our best video this year about yeah
seriously uh we played it so much in the
office
merry cash sick ass training
skipped that part
it has a bunch of dlc stuff that they
kept adding to it so you kept wanting to
come back they just added the uh ice
hockey stuff as well i think like
yesterday and so the office is playing
that like it's a game i played here in
the office played at home uh with with
people and also just online with randoms
like it's a game which is super fun to
keep going back to uh over and over and
over again uh i wonder if uh it's gonna
be interesting because we've talked
about a lot of games via the hashtag
duracell sweeps and also what we said
here on the couch it'll be interesting
to see how many of those games made it
into our top 10 list
yeah and what order they might be in as
well but no matter what the order you
have a chance of winning all 10 of what
we have decided the best games of 2015.
your platform of choice unless we can't
give it to you
on i was about to say something god that
was so so close unless it's not on a
different platform
let's say uh to do that all you have to
do is go to a link on gamespot.com which
should hopefully there you go yeah there
it is uh gamestop.com forward slash
duracell sweeps
uh go in there fill out a little form
and you have a chance to win what we
decided we're the top 10 games of 2015
and make sure you check back gamespot
all this week and next to find out what
our top 25 list is as well so the
14 15 games that won't get you won't get
if you entered this competition uh folks
thanks for coming on today and uh
talking about video games our last lobby
of 2015.
whatever you smell like remember that
time you were there and i was here
and then you had the simplest moment
you had that really like cynical comment
and then i came back to you with a
really dumb joke and then mike mugged
for the camera about time i kept putting
my laptop and peter single
there it is
there's a thing now i'm gonna do this
across the office at everybody
oh jesus it's a beautiful thing
somebody gift that give it to me
thanks so much everyone who's uh watched
the show as well over the course of 2015
i will be back next year with an even
better show and thanks to everyone in
production as ever mary kish joshua eric
tay
dan mahoric
and god and ty because he sometimes
wanders in there in this stuff as well
and warren goff
we're in dog
you're the man build us a beautiful set
and get well see tyrone because he's
sick at the moment we have an incubation
at the moment yeah he's in a room by
himself just locked in working he's
booked a meeting room all day no he's
playing uh also daunting don't go in
that room tomorrow
it's just going to be yeah
his diseased parts
heart disease all right we got a bunch
more work to do because game of the year
is still going crazy on gamespot.com so
thanks so much for tuning in to the
lobby today and all of the other weeks
in 2015 we'll be back uh first week of
february next year have a great new year
happy holidays and we'll see you on the
other side adios
you